So, I'm going to share some data looking at the feasibility of rapid dose escalation
scheduled Bispecific for relapsed refractory large B-cell lymphoma.
Okay.
So, for people less familiar with the lymphoma bispecifics, EPCORIDOMAB and GLOFIDOMAB are
CD20-CD3 Bispecific approved for use in relapsed refractory large B-cell lymphoma.
And in pivotal trials, CRS occurs in about 50% to 60% of patients treated with EPCORIDOMAB
and GLOFIDOMAB monotherapy, and ICANS in about 6% to 8% of patients.
And to mitigate the risk of CRS in ICANS, we use step-up dosing in addition to a pretreatment
dose of obinutuzumab prior to GLOFIDOMAB.
However, this, of course, delays the first full dose of therapeutic Bispecific
till day 15 and 22, respectively.
And for patients with very proliferative lymphoma,
the rate of progression may outpace step-up dosing,
necessitating earlier delivery of the first full dose of Bispecific.
Okay.
So, this was the impetus for a rapid dose escalation schedule of EPCORIDOMAB at my institution,
which is shown here.
So, we give EPCORIDOMAB on day 1, 4, 7.
Each dose is preceded by a clinic visit, and then EPCORIDOMAB is given outpatient.
And on day 7, patients are admitted to the hospital for a minimum of 24 hours,
although hopefully this will be changing in the future.
Okay.
Patients get dexamethasone, 16 milligrams, on days 1 through 11.
And then they're also sent home with a pill-in-pocket steroid dose of 12 milligrams
with instructions to take their temperature twice daily
if they have a fever, to take the dexamethasone, and then call a clinic.
And after treating the first 10 patients with this step-up dosing schedule,
we reported CRS in 50% of the patients.
And you can see eight of them had large B-cell lymphoma and 2-CLL.
And importantly, there were no grade 3 or higher rates of CRS,
and there were no reported cases of ICANS.
And this was particularly relevant for us because the University of Utah
is the largest referral center in the Mountain West United States.
And among the six patients that were residing outside of Utah,
four of them were able to return back to their referring provider.
So, this also, you know, laid the foundation for a much larger multi-institutional study.
And this was a multi-center retrospective study of real-world patients
with non-Hodgkin lymphoma treated with EBCO or Glofit
at nine centers in the collaborative U.S. bispecific consortium, which we call QBIC.
And we defined a rapid dose escalation schedule as omission of obinutuzumab
in the case of glofitumab and or a dose escalation schedule
with at least one step-up dosing interval that was shorter than the standard of care dosing.
And we compared patients treated on a rapid dose escalation schedule
to a time-matched cohort of patients treated with EBCO.
EBCO or Glofit on a non-rapid schedule.
And then, importantly, a comment about our statistics.
So, we used a propensity score matching analysis to balance relevant clinical variables
and additionally did a sensitivity analysis using inverse propensity weighting
to strengthen this primary analysis.
So, in total, we...
Identified 38 patients that were treated with a rapid dose escalation schedule
and 307 treated on a standard dose escalation schedule.
And these are the baseline characteristics at Bispecific start in the unmatched cohort.
And the important thing I want to point out is that the rapid patients were enriched with high-risk features
and they had significantly more high-grade B-cell lymphoma patients
and patients with an elevated LDH.
So, among the 12 patients that were treated with a rapid dose escalation schedule,
with EBCO, the median time from step-up dose 1 to the first full dose of EBCO was 6 days.
And the most common regimen was day 1, 4, and 7.
And then, among the 26 patients that were treated with Glofit on a rapid schedule,
the median time from step-up dose 1 to the first full dose was 14 days.
And the two most common regimens were either omission of obinutuzumab
and day 1 obinutuzumab with step-up dose 1 on day 3.
In the unmatched cohort,
the rates of CRS in the rapid group were 47% and about 38% in the standard group.
And the rates of ICANNs in the rapid group was 21% and about 13% in the standard group.
However, I want to point out that in the case of both CRS and ICANNs,
most cases were grade 1 or 2 and the rates of grade 3 or higher CRS and ICANNs
were comparable between the two groups and those reported in pivotal trials in real-world studies.
Again, in the unmatched cohort, we see comparable overall response rates
between the two groups, albeit lower CRR rates in the rapid group.
And then importantly, the time to best response in the rapid cohort was nearly half of the non-rapid
cohort at 34 days versus 62 days. And then probably most importantly, so in this propensity-matched
analysis where we balance these covariates that we know can impact both CRS and ICANNs, as well as response rates and survival rates and survival rates between the two groups,
and then probably most importantly, so in this propensity-matched analysis where we balance these covariates that we know can impact both CRS and ICANNs, as well as response rates and survival rates between the two groups,
what we see is that there is no significant association between a rapid dose escalation
and CRS or ICANNs, which is shown in that upper blue box.
And similarly, there was no significant association between a rapid dose escalation schedule
and an overall response rate and/or complete response rate shown in the lower orange box.
And similarly, in this propensity-matched cohort, when we looked at PFS and OS,
although that we see the standard group,
which is shown in the lower orange box,
which is shown in the pinkish color,
had numerically longer median PFS and OS,
this was not statistically significant.
And again, when we specifically looked at the association between a rapid dose escalation schedule,
and sorry, that's a typo, it should say PFS and OS,
there was no significant association.
So, in conclusion, as it stands to our knowledge,
this is currently the largest real-world analysis of patients treated with Glofit and EPCO
on a rapid dose escalation schedule.
And using a very robust statistical model
to account for confounding baseline features,
we saw that a rapid dose escalation schedule
did not significantly impact CRS-ICANN's response rates or survival outcomes
when compared to a propensity-matched population of patients.
And it also resulted in a shorter time to best response.
And then because I have 14 seconds,
I'll skip ahead and just say our study supports the utilization
of a rapid dose escalation schedule for Glofit or EPCO
when treating patients with aggressive B-cell lymphoma.
Okay.